forgive me Father for I have sinned
it's been like two months since my last
confession it's been over three years
Rick oh it's kind of embarrassing but
here's how the whole thing went down I
had fallen in love and her name was Nina
Pennington
hi I'm Rick Stevens that's lo kid from
Latin class
I know unfortunately this is pretty much
a true story who said that you could
talk to my girlfriend douchebag not your
girlfriend Kevin you're a dead man Ricky
it's very important to try new things
you're trying to seduce me I want to be
your teacher you just raise your hand if
you have any questions she awoke in your
brothel they can touch you but you can't
touch them
Rick
why are all these girls naked yes weird
right
yeah everybody freeze this is what my
parents are trying to shelter me from at
the rate your family and friends keep
going to jail you should put me on a
permanent retainer I have a message for
you from God stop being such a screw-up
oh and don't lose faith all I ever
wanted was for you liking is the most
exciting thing I've ever done you're in
quite the pickle aren't you
what's going on in here I'm working on
putting a breakfast buffet in here eggs
and sausage and a lap dance all in 1299
but you're present within the night who
will eat your head while you're sleeping
shouldn't we call the police
I don't think that's necessary this
totally reminds me of a German porno I
download oddly enough actually I had fun
yes we'll have to do it again sometime
you